hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge mit
diary
wer diese videoreihe noch gar nicht
gesehen hat der sollte jetzt ganz
schnell alle anderen teile schauen und
dann zurückkommen für alle anderen viel
spaß also das letzte mal haben wir damit
aufgehört dass ich in den ferien marvin
fragen wollte mir zusammen sein möchte
weil alle guten dinge drei sind so das
letzte mal hatten wir den 15 6 und heute
den 16 06 2005 hallo heute über handball
da haben wir weßling gespielt ich bin
öfters auf wallach drauf gefallen und
dann hat marvin immer so komisch geguckt
er war bestimmt eifersüchtig aber es war
cool wallach ist echt nett aber marvin
ist toller und ihn kann kenne ich besser
dann bis dann bei vanessa dann bist dann
sieht so aus ist wie ein tag später
immer noch auf ihn standen warum jetzt
haben wir den 21 06 2005
was bei dir sohn los bei mir nicht es
ist ein buch was kann bei diesem
tagebuch schon los sein außer dass ich
so verknallt in marvin will er ist so
süß offen ein gehalt noch nicht wann es
auch noch nicht
ich finde mein physik buch nicht aber es
war die ganze zeit in der schule
naja ich und andré verstehen uns auch
immer besser sorry dass ich so lange
nicht geschrieben habe das war nur vier
tage so lang war das gar nicht wenn es
ja ich wette unter euch gibt leute die
noch unregelmäßig an ihr tagebuch
geschrieben haben als ich einen tag
später 22.6 seit 2005 hallo also ich und
sophie wollten heute zu marvin er hat
auch nichts dagegen gesagt und dann als
sophie noch gefragt hat nach der schule
waren wir noch mal kommen sollen hat er
gesagt er fährt angel
das glaube ich aber nicht er spinnt doch
andré ist voll nett ein guter kumpel
mehr nicht bei vanessa doch dazu
schreiben muss also wirklich ein guter
kumpel also ich mag ihn aber ich liebe
ihn nicht wirklich ich liebe ihn nicht
lass doch mal hinfahren und wenn nicht
dann nicht
noch einen tag später dreiundzwanzigster
sechster 2005 hallo ich habe heute voll
den sonnenbrand gekriegt das brennt wie
sau
und heute war chaoten tag marvin ist so
toll ich bin so in ihn verknallt das
glaubst du gar nicht könnte das noch
glauben ich kann das nicht mehr glauben
ich glaub mir wert denn schon die ganze
zeit zusammen wir also ich und angriffs
zu tanken
ich glaube wir waren schon die ganze
zeit zu sammeln wir also wenn wir also
ich und angriffs waren in ihrem
swimmingpool beiden esser ich wirklich
so cool wie an chris man noch seine
rolle bekommt über seinen letzten satz
noch rund bei anderes wort super ich
glaube ich hab die ganze zeit auch immer
nur mit angriff gespielt und in der
schule waren auch die drama und bei
angriffs seien aber so schwer wie cool
naja diese sachen so erster siebter 2005
hi heute schreibe ich mal früher rein es
ist 9 uhr 30
wir schlafen nämlich heute mit der
ganzen klasse zelten mit marshmallows
grillen und so was soll ich noch sagen
ach ja ich schlaf mit sophie frau und
mit seinem kopf und vielleicht anderes
in einem zelt bei vanessa ich habe
wirklich frei und konnten so sternchen
geschrieben sehr gut
langsam versuche ich auch schüler zu
schreiben ich werde erwachsen leute ich
werde erwachsen zweiter siebter 2005
meinte ich bin wieder morgen zusammen
aber dieses mal ist es ernst und wir
umarmen uns
die ganze zeit und manchmal gibt es dann
auch ein kuss auf die wange
ich ließ mich alleine denn ihr hört mir
alle zu danke das waren solo angelique
hat geheult als sie das erfahren hat
morgen geht ich mit ihm eis essen dann
bis bald und viel spaß
vanessa tatsächlich marvins nachnamen
hinter meinen namen geschrieben so weit
war das schon ich hatte schon
hochzeitspläne bauleute okay ich sehe
schon das war nämlich der zweite siebte
und das nächste mal ist der dreizehnte
achte und ihr wisst wie vanessa mit
marvin ist und jetzt zum hundertsten mal
werde ich mit marvin zusammenbleiben und
was ist mit angelique und was ist mit
wallach und was ist mit angriffen über
an crysis mal alles in ordnung und jetzt
nicht gerade hier sitze fällt mir auf
dass ich mit ann-christin etwas
gemeinsam hat und zwar wir uns beim
firma zvs kassetten gekauft und
versuchte alle zu sammeln und dann
aufgeteilt leute es wird immer
spannender also schaltet auch das
nächste mal ein wenn ich wieder aus
meinem tagebuch vorlese und die
peinlichsten geheimnisse meiner
vergangenheit aufdecken
bis dann
[Musik]
ich bin aus dem bild heraus